Rihanna can do no wrong ever
now I don't mean to take away from her
she is talented as all get out she's got
a great voice and she's beautiful
and she's just cool right
big Rihanna I didn't know she had she
said second of the Super Bowl I'm like
she got that many hits
they kept coming dude I'm watching her
do the thing and she can do no wrong
like honestly Rihanna could legitimately
have like
she could go rob a bank without a mask
and people be like well she deserves
that money
and people be like it was actually my
money at the bank and they said yeah but
you're not Rihanna
and they go what
what what I mean
but why does she get it she sings Rude
Boy
and you're like all right
I guess just kind of shitty it was
she took five thousand dollars for me
and so much from other people like all
throughout it like yeah but
umbrella
she's super sexy but she's one of those
women that everyone talks about is so
beautiful that they just it's like okay
dude
all right she was good and she was
pregnant and that was amazing because
let me tell you something dude she
performed halftime she does this thing
where she's like I'm Dan she's a great
dancer but she didn't really do it this
time because she's pregnant and she's
doing the thing where she's like I don't
give a [__] about the dancing I'm cool I
do whatever I want and it was very cool
how she was doing it was great it was a
great performance I do feel like Rihanna
was killing it
and then I'm like okay so she's pregnant
and then I'm like how far along is she I
guess she's having another baby with
ASAP Rocky right that's who it is
because she had to run recently and
apparently he [__] squirted all up in
her immediately after because she's
already pregnant again although I'm no
good with time like if you ask me when
the Razor scooter came out I'd be like I
was at 2016 and people were like dude it
was the 80s and I'm like oh I'm not good
with time she does the dancing and the
singing and her voice is amazing and
she's way Sky High up into the
I mean she's on a plank that's like also
by the way like super if she fell off no
more Rihanna
like like zero like zero more real if
she fell off just no more shine bright
like a diamond shine bright like a
diamond
zero more shining like a diamond more
just being in the dirt really dark dead
so she's on this plank and it's like
wobbly and she's just sitting there just
[__] shine bright like a dying
umbrella
just killing it I'm not doing too much
dancing because she's pregnant I thought
in the beginning I was like oh she's not
doing too much dancing because she's on
a plank she could follow up and break
all of her but no the truth is she
revealed the bump but didn't even do a
thing like look at my bump she was just
like I have a bump and I don't give a
[__] about y'all and that's super
Rihanna and I love that crazy
congratulations
[Music]